evening everyone welcome to the next
revolution I'm Steve Hilton and this is
the home of positive populism pro-worker
pro-family pro community lots to get to
tonight we have an exclusive interview
with Health and Human Services Secretary
Lex a czar which is just great you will
be so impressed with him I promise and
we have the start of a new occasional
series which I think you'll enjoy yes an
update on the real collusion scandal get
ready to break out that Joe China
hashtag again tonight but first the
manufactured scandal populism is about
fighting a corrupt establishment and boy
did we see them in action this week this
was the week that Robert Miller put
himself in the arena with his bizarre
new doctrine of not not guilty he
overturned the presumption of innocence
then with his unsubtle a coded call for
the impeachment of President Trump he
revealed his real aim overturning the
2016 election Mulla was hired to be a
neutral arbiter to bring a clear
conclusion that the country could unite
behind but on Wednesday he ripped off
the mask of neutrality and showed
himself for what he is a partisan in the
fight between the populist and the
establishment we shouldn't be surprised
he is the establishment he's a swamp
lawyer as we told you months ago in our
swamp watch episode on Miller and his
best buddy James Comey remember Robert
Miller was previously director of the
FBI and James Comey was previously
Deputy Attorney General by an incredible
coincidence
once Comey left that job to become the
multi-million dollar general counsel of
defense giant Lockheed Martin Lockheed
Martin was awarded contract after
contract over a billion dollars worth by
robert miller's FBI and there's more as
we told you Robert Miller's swamp onus
goes beyond awarding billion dollar
contracts to his best friends employer
after leaving his post as FBI director
what did this modern-day Saint this
paragon of ethics and integrity do he
cashed in of course Muller went
to work for his old law and lobbying
firm now called Wilmer Hale and surprise
surprise his clients were directly
related to his previous government work
one of them was Booz Allen Hamilton like
Lockheed Martin a giant surveillance
contractor Bloomberg has called them the
world's most profitable spy agency that
is the establishment code you protect
each other always and you take down any
and every threat to your power that's
how to understand
last week's extraordinary intervention
by Muller
it was the establishments final stand
against their mortal enemy Trump and the
peasants revolt he led in 2016 they
tried to stop him getting elected by
clearing Hillary Clinton they tried to
bring him down by manufacturing a Russia
collusion scandal and when all that
failed last week Robert Miller played
the obstruction card strip away all the
tortured legalese and intellectual
incoherence it all boiled down to one
thing
Mulla saying I can't prove he did it but
he did it he talked about another
process and with that weak pathetic
attempt to hide the explosive nature of
what he was really saying Miller called
on Congress to impeach the president
impeach him for what he didn't plot with
Putin to steal the election Muller found
no evidence for that crazed
establishment fantasy despite two years
of trying the president didn't obstruct
justice
mullet found no evidence of that either
as he himself admitted in a
clarification put out later that same
day Moniz claimed that it was the
regulation about not indicted a sitting
president that stopped him recommending
charges that was a lie let's be really
clear about that Robert Miller yes the
straight shooting man of integrity
Robert Miller lied from the podium last
Wednesday
he lied to cover up the fact that he
didn't find evidence of obstruction to
justify a criminal charge what did he
find stories about the president losing
his temper of course he lost his temper
if a totally manufactured conspiracy
theory about you being a traitor to your
country and colluding with an
power derails your presidency for years
wouldn't you be annoyed about it
this was eruption not obstruction what
we're gonna impeach a president for
venting now by that standard we should
impeach Amy Klobuchar for that business
with the salad and the comb as The Wall
Street Journal put it Robert Miller
wants an impeachment inquiry to charge
Donald Trump with obstructing an
investigation that wasn't obstructed
into a conspiracy that didn't exist
Muller the straight-shooter with that
bumbling malicious press conference he
shot himself straight in the foot his
reputation is destroyed and he's got no
one to blame but himself but now it's
time to fight back against the
establishment it's good that the origins
of the plot against President Trump are
now being investigated but let's not
leave it there what mullah did at his
press conference wasn't justice
it wasn't the rule of law it was a smear
a false statement designed to cause
material harm to president Trump
delivered with malice you know what that
is
the legal standard for defamation
President Trump should sue Robert Miller
for libel next let's open a corruption
investigation into the business dealings
of Miller and Comey in their swampy
trips around the revolving door let's
investigate those Lockheed Martin
contracts let's investigate those client
relationships that Miller's swamp law
firm where he had a conflict of interest
was there personal financial corruption
let's investigate after all what's that
phrase we've been hearing these last
couple of years we need to get to the
bottom of it if mother and Comey have
done nothing wrong they've got nothing
to fear from a corruption investigation
right and let's take the fight to the
ridiculous
never Trump as to led by Bill Kristol
they're now joining the impeachment
bandwagon with new ads under the banner
of Republicans for the rule of law they
say they're defending democracy excuse
me they are literally attacking
democracy trying to overturn the
democratic election of a president they
despise they talk about decency and
honor and morality
morality did they bring to the table by
the way they're demented ideology sent
millions to their deaths in Middle East
Wars and cost our country trillions of
dollars their dinner party decadence
brought the authoritarian despots of
China to the brink of world domination
and their Craven genuflect onto big
business destroyed the American Dream
for middle-class families these never
trumpets this corrupt establishment it
is rotten it has failed but it's not
dead yet they think they can kick out
Trump and take back power do not let
them it's time to fight them it is time
to defeat them all right tell me what
you think of that at Steve Hilton X and
that next Rev offense